buques cargados con grandes tesoros
aventureros surcando los siete mares
banderas negras con calaveras y huesos
cruzados feroces corsarios con parches
en el ojo y patas de palo
[Música]
leyendas que ponen los pelos de punta
como las de barba negra francis drake o
henry morgan piratas filibusteros
bucaneros corsarios que durante siglos
han surcado los mares en busca de oro
plata y piedras preciosas decidme quién
de vosotros no ha crecido con historias
de feroces intrépidos y osados piratas
con leyendas como las de barba negra
novelas como la isla del tesoro o
personajes como el capitán jack sparrow
a lo largo de la historia de la
humanidad los piratas han causado
fascinación admiración o terror pero no
penséis ni por un momento que han
desaparecido
[Aplausos]
las guerras ya no se libran únicamente
por tierra mar y aire ahora en nuestros
días cada vez más lo hacen también por
el ciberespacio
para nada
a ver no creo que esto sea algo que os
sorprenda a ninguno de vosotros un país
puede causar un enorme daño a otro país
simplemente atacando sus sistemas
informáticos imaginaos todo lo que se
puede hacer lo que a sistemas de
comunicación transporte equipos
eléctricos los sistemas financieros y
prácticamente cualquier cosa porque hoy
a casi todo funciona con ordenadores
esto es algo que todas las potencias y
prácticamente todos los países del mundo
lo saben incluido amigos corea del norte
[Música]
si habéis escuchado bien un momento no
os lo creéis pues amigos no deberíais
ser tan incrédulos veréis durante los
últimos años el país más cerrado más
hermético del planeta no sólo ha
desarrollado un arsenal de armas
nucleares también se ha montado su
propio equipo de hackers
en 1998 kim jong-il el anterior líder de
corea del norte y padre del actual líder
kim jong-un estableció la que se conoce
como unidad 121 un cuerpo de guerra
cibernética que según se cree está
formado por miles de personas que
trabajan mañana tarde y noche
preparándose para sembrar el caos con
ataques cibernéticos contra redes de
comunicaciones energía y todo tipo de
infraestructuras estratégicas de los
adversarios del régimen de pyongyang
[Música]
sí sé que puede parecer algo muy extraño
y todo una paradoja que uno de los
regímenes más herméticos y pobres del
mundo en un país donde el acceso a
internet está muy pero que muy
restringido y donde incluso el gobierno
ha desarrollado su propio internet una
especie de intranet súper cutre y muy
vigilada cuenta con uno de los ejércitos
de hackers más peligrosos de toda la red
para ellos el arma más poderosa es
cibernética en corea del norte se le
conoce como la guerra secreta los
incentivos para los ciber expertos de
corea del norte son muy fuertes son
gente rica en pyongyang yangtsé llull
antiguo estudiante de la escuela militar
de ciencias de la computación de corea
del norte amigos la persona que hizo
estas declaraciones a reuters jiang seúl
es un joven norcoreano que antes de huir
a corea del sur estudió codo con codo
con jóvenes que hoy integran la unidad
su testimonio corrobora lo que muchos
expertos llevan defendiendo años para el
régimen norcoreano sus unidades de
guerra cibernética son toda una
prioridad de hecho la unidad 121 depende
ni más ni menos que de la dirección
general de reconocimientos una agencia
de inteligencia que informa y responde
directamente ante el mismísimo kim
jong-un
[Música]
y no sólo eso según algunas estimaciones
estos equipos de ataques cibernéticos
compuestos por casi 2000 hackers podrían
estar acaparando entre el 10 y el 20 por
ciento de todo el presupuesto militar
norcoreano creo que esto ya no está una
idea muy clara de la enorme importancia
que tiene para el régimen
pues bien según se cree su primer ataque
a gran escala se produjo en el año 2013
veréis haciendo uso de un malware
conocido como dark souls estos equipos
de hacker consiguieron borrar una enorme
cantidad de datos y congelar o apagar
alrededor de 32 mil 32 mil equipos en
corea del sur- equipos entre los que se
encontraban los servidores de cuatro
grandes bancos y tres agencias de
televisión surcoreanas y ojo porque todo
esto no es ninguna broma
apenas un año más tarde en 2014 la
corporación de energía nuclear de corea
del sur anunció que sus sistemas
informáticos habían sido hackeados
los hackers norcoreanos habían robado
planos de sus reactores nucleares
información personal sobre sus más de 10
mil empleados y otra información no
revelada
desde entonces los ataques que los
hackers norcoreanos han llevado a lo
largo y ancho del mundo han sido
continuos convirtiéndose en todo un
quebradero de cabeza una pesadilla para
muchas empresas y gobiernos
por ejemplo en el año 2017 estos mismos
tipos al servicio de kim jong-un
lanzaron el virus wanna cry que se
convirtió en el mayor ataque con
software maligno de toda la historia se
estima que afectó a más de 300.000
equipos y que puso contra las cuerdas a
multinacionales de la talla de fedex o
telefónica los gobiernos de estados
unidos y reino unido han dicho que corea
del norte fue responsable del ataque de
malware wanna cry que afectó a
hospitales negocios y bancos en todo el
mundo un detalle importante estos
hackers no sólo operan desde corea del
norte una vez que han sido formados
muchos de estos hackers se envían a
china al sudeste asiático oa otros
países con identidades falsas para que
puedan actuar de daddy sorprendidos pues
esperad un momento porque corea del
norte amigos tiene otra unidad de
ciberguerra que cree os va a llamar aún
más la atención
unidad 180 asalto al tesoro de corea del
norte no se ha llevado nunca
precisamente bien con la comunidad
internacional sin embargo desde que kim
jong-un llegó al poder en el año 2011 y
aceleró el programa nuclear norcoreano
las sanciones contra este país se han
multiplicado
y amigos desarrollar un programa nuclear
y balístico no es algo que resulte
precisamente barato así que la pregunta
es si las sanciones internacionales te
cortan el grifo y te impiden comerciar
con el resto del mundo entonces qué
diantres puedes hacer para obtener las
divisas que necesitas para seguir
comprando en el mercado negro todo lo
que requieres para completar tu programa
nuclear
alguna idea amigos esta es la pregunta
que kim jong-un se hizo muy pronto y
sabéis que en su caso su respuesta fue
la unidad 180
en 2013 cuando quimio gum empezaba a
sentir la presión de las sanciones
internacionales decidió establecer la
conocida como unidad 180 con 500
profesionales de la unidad 121 con qué
objetivo hackear la mayor cantidad
posible de cuentas bancarias y de cripto
divisas para obtener recursos con los
que financiar su programa nuclear y
balístico
si lo habéis escuchado bien en el año
2013 corea del norte se montó su propia
unidad de atracadores cibernéticos un
enorme equipo dedicado a robar dinero
para pagar los caprichos del líder
el principal trabajo de la unidad 180 es
obtener divisas extranjeras para
financiar proyectos para desarrollar
cinco grandes armas incluyendo bombas
nucleares misiles de largo alcance y
misiles balísticos para ser lanzados
desde submarinos kim hyun cuán antiguo
profesor de ciencias de la computación
en una universidad norcoreana pues bien
desde que fue montada esta unidad 180 ha
llevado a cabo numerosos robos decenas y
decenas de robos contra bancos y
entidades de intercambio de cristo'
divisas de todo el mundo bueno en el año
2016 incluso de robaron algo más de 100
100 millones de dólares al banco central
de bangladesh la desesperación del
gobierno norcoreano por el dinero en
efectivo está impulsando el aumento de
los ataques cibernéticos contra bancos y
otras empresas de los eeuu y del resto
del mundo los norcoreanos se han
convertido rápidamente en los más
avanzados y persistentes ladrones
digitales de bancos está claro que las
sanciones económicas internacionales
están funcionando y han obligado a los
norcoreanos a recurrir
alternativos para conseguir ingresos
anthony ferrante ex funcionario de
ciberseguridad del fbi y de la casa
blanca grupos tan conocidos en la red
como la haru's o reaper dependen de esta
unidad 180 y por tanto del gobierno
norcoreano si la verdad es que corea del
norte es ha tomado muy pero que muy en
serio eso de convertirse en algo así
como el malo malísimo de la política
internacional armas nucleares hackers
secuestros tráfico de armas no importa
si es ilegal y es considerado malo kim
jong-un se encarga
[Música]
ahora bien la gran pregunta realmente
cuánto dinero han podido robar estos
hackers norcoreanos en los últimos años
pues no es algo fácil de determinar pero
un panel de expertos que informa el
consejo de seguridad de las naciones
unidas ha estimado que durante los
últimos años especialmente desde el año
pyongyang ha acumulado alrededor de 670
millones de dólares en moneda extranjera
y cripto divisas
[Música]
casi 700 millones de dólares que se
sepan robados por la unidad 180 bancos e
intermediarios de cripto divisas luego
además utilizan block change para cubrir
sus huellas y transferir todo este
dinero a donde lo necesitan por ejemplo
para pagar a sus proveedores de equipos
tecnológicos en el mercado negro
ya lo veis según parece el gobierno de
corea del norte está pagando buena parte
de su programa nuclear con cripto isas
que evidentemente son más difíciles de
rastrear y no dependen de la regulación
internacional
pero aquí amigos no terminan todas las
actividades de la unidad 180 para
conseguir pasta como han cogido
experiencia además de trincar la unidad
180 también desarrolla software para
empresas internacionales especialmente
de japón y china- oye ya que estamos y
tenemos a todos estos hackers pues habrá
que aprovecharlo pues bien estos
curiosos pedidos son coordinados por
algunos de los grupos pro corea del
norte que hay por el mundo por supuesto
esta unidad 180 ofrece unas tarifas por
los suelos y en muchos casos las
empresas contratantes ni siquiera saben
que están haciendo negocios con la
inteligencia norcoreana
y eso amigos es algo que implica un
riesgo muy pero que muy alto porque pues
porque según parece estos programas
suelen venir repletos de puertas
traseras que he llegado el momento le
podrían permitir a los servicios
secretos a la inteligencia norcoreana
controlar los dispositivos donde se
instala este software ya sea para
bloquearlos hoy para seguir trincando
pasta no me digáis que estos tipos del
régimen norcoreano no son todos los
bandidos
las compañías de software que la unidad
180 ha establecido en países como
vietnam o malasia están ocultas como
compañías normales y han suministrado
sistemas de control de fábricas y otros
productos a empresas japonesas fumiaki
yamasaki experto en seguridad de la
información en fin amigos esta es la
historia de como corea del norte se las
ha ingeniado para desarrollar poderosos
equipos de ciberguerra y conseguir
cientos de millones de dólares con los
que saltarse las acciones
internacionales y sacar adelante su
programa nuclear los tiempos han
cambiado y tal vez ya no hablemos de
surcar los mares o de piratas con parche
en el ojo pero aquí estamos hablando
básicamente de piratería y al fin y al
cabo la red es algo así como una especie
de gran océano por cierto os habéis
preguntado alguna vez de dónde diantres
viene lo de los piratas y el parche en
el ojo
[Música]
es que acaso a todos los piratas
normalmente les faltaba un ojo pues no
nada de eso según parece el parche tenía
una función muy pero que muy útil
adaptarse mejor a los cambios bruscos de
luz por ejemplo cuando abordaban otro
barco y entraban en su bodega
si veréis el ojo humano tarda un montón
en acostumbrarse a la oscuridad y
evidentemente ese es un tiempo que no se
tiene en pleno abordaje así que los
piratas estaban un ojo para que éste se
adaptará muy rápido a la oscuridad es
decir cuando entraba en un espacio más
oscuro rápidamente se cambiaban el
parche de un lado igual veían
estupendamente eso es lo que parece y
ojo que no es ninguna tontería es algo
que se utiliza hoy en los mismísimos
entrenamientos de la nasa en fin amigos
espero que este vídeo os haya resultado
interesante como siempre si ha sido así
echarnos una mano dándole like y
compartiéndolo con tus amigos un saludo
y hasta la próxima
[Música]
[Aplausos]